Mark: Can I join?
Wade: Why Not, I'm not in yet, but sure.
Mark: Ok I'm joining
Jack: You better- no foolies?
Mark: No goofsies!
Wade: I think I've already done this one, I don't think this is the right map
Wade: But,
Wade: But, I'll join anyway
Jack: No gafs?
Wade: N-No, this is a prank bro
Mark: There better not be any Guffaws!
Jack: This is a luhmao, bro
Wade: No, there's 2 Jaffars but no Juffaws
Mark: I've got, you know,
Mark: The will,
Bob: That jokes not good
Jack: Dude I've got broads in Atlanta
*Empty Chamber Click*
Jack: It's me and Bumbers
Mark: Yeah! Remember how you were insulting me last time?
Mark: Maybe, maybe a compliment to start this off? Would be nice?
Wade: Oh, I have done this map before, (It's a ver- This map is Huge)
Jack: Wade, you are a great guy, we're gonna make a great team!
Mark: Aww thanks, your accent is not nearly as funny as people make it out to be,
Mark: It's actually cool and probably voted the #1 sexiest accent in the world
Jack: It is, but I'm also terrible at it and my accent is so (Mark: Oh wait, oh wait,) neutral now.
Mark: Isn't it the northern accent that's the sexy one?
Jack: No they don't count.
Jack: They're not Irish they're British
Mark: ooOOOOoh.
Jack: DUDE WAFFLE HOUSE!
*Bob Giggles*
Mark: Wat the fuck?
Jack: Whoa!
Mark: WHOA!
Mark: Heh, fuck this map let's go to waffle house!
Bob: Alright, I'll go to waffle house
Wade: Yeah I'll go.
Jack: There's a fuckin',
Jack: a T-pose dude just standing in there
Mark: Is that, one of the- *giggles*
Jack: I don't think you can actually go in
Mark: Is that one of them?
Jack: Yup, Slenderman's in there as well
Bob: You can't go in, don't
Bob: You can't so you shouldn't.
Mark: This is a spooky map!
*Bob and Jack laughing*
*Mark fake shudders*
Jack: SPOOKY-
Mark: Woah what the fu- I saw Felix's face in the window
Mark: What the fuck
Wade: I think your face is in one of them too Mark
Jack: Woah, yeah!
*Mark laughing*
Mark: Ah jeezus
Mark: Alright wait, do it again.
Mark: Yep, there it is
Jack: Oh yours is in this one
Mark: Which one?
Jack: Your face is in here
Mark: Is yours in one of these?
Jack: No, I'm not the horror game dude.
Mark: Oh my god, I, I re- I remember that photoshop that it's showing
Mark: I, I remember that one
Jack: Ye heh heh heh
Mark: Ulgh..
Jack: Show it again!
*Jack making puking noises*
*Mark's turn*
Mark: My face...
Mark: No...
Mark: You sudnut come here
Mark: Okeh.
*Jack laughing softly*
Jack: I'm gonna - the SCARY grammar
*Mark Laughing*
Wade: I mean, Bob and I were here looking in the windows with you guys
Wade: I mean, Bob and I were here looking in the windows with you guys, but...
Mark: Oh jeezus
Mark: Ok.
Jack: Oh hey
Bob: Nope.
Bob: Nope that's not me, that's not me. Don't worry about it.
Jack: What!?
Jack: He's behind you!
Mark: Woah- uh, I saw him.
Mark: Wait, where'd he go?
Mark: Fuck I lost him, sorry guys.
Jack: How the FUCK did I miss with that?
Mark: I don't know
Mark: He went under my feet and then I immediately
Mark: wait there he is
Bob: OH GOD
Bob: ah fuck
Mark: Wait I spot him, I spot him.
Bob: oh FUCK!
Jack: Wade's out here, Wade's out here! He's a little doll
Mark: Where is he?
Jack: I got him cornered!
Jack: He's out here!
Jack: Behind the wood!
Mark: You're not giving me descriptive-
Wade: Oh hey
Mark: COMMUNICATION
Mark: COMMUNICATION IS THE KEY
Jack: GOT'EM
Mark: Alright, for this one rule, we have to chase people
Mark: Otherwise nothing'll happen
Bob: I was chasing you that entire time so that's cool
Wade: Do we have to stay outside cause this map is so big or what?
*Jack giggles*
Jack: *Still giggling* Are you thinking what I'm thinkin'?
Mark: Oh you were thinkin' what I'm thinking?
Mark: Ok, we can think- we can think what we were thinkin'
Wade: Wait wait wait, are you guys thinkin what Bob and I are thinkin?
Bob: I can smell the dickery through the internet right now
*Bob Sniffing*
Mark: You guys thinking what I'm thinking?
*Bob's sniffing intensifies*
Wade: I mean I showered last night so I'm not sure if it's me
Bob: I smell...
Mark: *Sniffing* MMM, that's some fresh DICK.
Bob: Not your dickery...
Bob: Not your dickly-ness.
Wade: Oh, ok
Mark: Yeah,
Mark: Little closer...
Mark: Little more...
Mark: Yeahhh...
Mark: *Evil HEH HEH*
Mark: Heh Heh Heh Heh Heh Heh Heh Heh
Mark: HEH HEH-
Mark: HEH HEH- AHH FUCK
Jack: IT'S NOT WORKING *jumps off roof*
*Mad laughs all around*
Jack: SHIT
Jack: *leaning back* Noooooooo
*Mad laughs all around*
Bob: Oh my god that was amazing
Mark: Jesus Christ.
Mark: That didn't work at ALL
Wade: I spawned on the roof right next to you two...
Jack: I COUNTED on his STUPIDITY!
Jack: In our defense there was 2 bottles right there that we threw off and sacrificed.
Wade: I really liked you guys jumping off the roof
Mark: I didn't jump off the roof, I comitted.
Jack: You got killed first!
Mark: WHATEVER!
Mark: I comitted!
Wade: Oh my god..
Wade: It's ok Bob, I smelled the dickery too
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Yeah you were all over that dickery
Mark: That STICKY dick
Wade: No, everythings fine
Jack: OWWW, broke my legs
*Window Shatters*
Mark: BOW... bitch.
Jack: THERE ARE BETTER WAYS
Bob: Oh my god what the fuck is happening?
Jack: What are you DOING?!
Mark: LEAVE ME TO MY DEVICES
*Jack scoffs*
Jack: There's a FUCKIN' front door!
Mark: There is?
Mark: Oh shit, whoops.
Bob: There's a purple room...
Wade: Is there somebody hobbling around outside?
Wade: Or breaking their legs?
Mark: No no no no no.
Jack: Yeah, I broke my legs.
Jack: Oh the front door was OPEN.
Mark: I was being an idiot.
Mark: Ohhh this DOOR.
Jack: Okay wait,
Jack: On a scale of how spoopy,
Jack: Where are we on this?
Mark: Hoh fuck, we're pretty spoopy.
Mark: We're pretty spoopy
Jack: I mean,
Jack: Imminent danger of skeletons is pretty spoopy..
Wade: You're definitely P spoopy
Mark: Hang on,
Mark: Wait a minute,
Mark: Wait a minute guys,
Jack: Wait a seccer...
Mark: Wait a minute guys...
Wade: OW, you knocked me over.
Jack: You do that I'll stay out here.
Jack: 4-10 buddy
Mark: Ok...
Jack: I got you.
Mark: What the fuck? Hi Sonic! what the fuck?
Mark: Oh Jesus
Jack: Dude, I think we're gonna have to upgrade this to a 2 spooky
Mark: This might be too spooky for me
Wade: It is too late the skeleton is inside you
Jack: It WAS P spoopy
Jack: Its gotten wo- oh you know what
Jack: You know how to read
Wade: I do
Jack: You know how to read the sign that means you're close
Mark: Yeah he is close cause he opened a door
Wade: Or maybe there is
Wade: the same poster in another place
*Wade giggles*
Mark: no nonono no
Bob: O dear
Mark: Jack! I found a watermelon
*Gunshots*
Jack: AH
*Mark's Laughter*
Jack: I-its not it GOD Don't scare me
Jack: like that
Mark: Oh shit
Mark: Oh sorry man
Mark: I thought for sure
Jack: Watermelons are my ENEMY
Mark: Oh No
Bob: Hey I made it
Wade: You did good bob
Jack: I- noo
Jack: Thats not something I want- oh hey
Mark: WATERMELON- oh
*gunshot*
Jack: Thats not something I wanna hear
Jack: Fuck! Jesus
*Group laughter*
Wade: I'm VERY glad I wasn't a watermelon now
Wade: Jeez
Bob: wwaTERMELON
Jack: ooO ok
Bob: Are you assholes still inside that house?
Mark: Yeah, why
Wade: yeah
Jack: hEY
Jack: How 'bout you be nicer to us
Bob: Well I'm gonnna get an advantage point, so I can
Jack: OK give us a hint
Bob: see you idiots
Jack: gimme a hint
Wade: um HINT
Wade: Im inside-a that house-*Breaks off into giggles*
*Bob giggles*
Mark: yoU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE CHASING
Bob: O right I forgot 'bout that
Jack: yEAH
Mark: yeAH Losers
Jack: Im usually the one that forgets that
Mark: wait a minute
*Gunshot*
Bob: Hint! I was chasing you in that house
Bob: and I was one of those bottles of bleach in the bathroom
Bob: that you looked right at
Mark: ooH Okay
Jack: oAWW and I was just about to drink you
Mark: awww
Wade: I was just tryin' to milk it for all its worth
Wade: o hey
Mark: WHOA! what the fuck
Wade: hey
Bob: I'm- I can wait
Wade: OW WHY
Bob: wa- wai- WAIT! Whoever just ran through a door
Mark: HAH
*Bomb explosion*
Bob: run back run back
Mark: *quietly* o shit
Bob: yeah now look up at the window
Mark: huh  Ahuh
Bob: now back up back up till you're
Bob: against the wall by the door
Mark: eh
*Glass shattering*
Mark: You weren't the window?
Jack: O hey-he Thats pretty fuckin' good
Bob: Hey
Mark: wha
Jack: he was on the wall out there
Mark: Ohhh- thATS THE WINDOWS
Mark: I WAS SMASHING AND YOU SAID I
Mark: WAS DUMB
*Bob giggles*
*Wade giggles*
Jack: well yEAH
Mark: heehheHEHA what yeah that's the point
Jack: You were going IN the house
Mark: ohhkay
Wade: I love this show, Bob
Jack: Oh He's back n the house
Bob: naw
Mark: Is he now?
Bob: I-is it all the door noises giving it away for you or what
*Mark & Jack giggle*
*Wade also giggles*
Jack: nnNO
Mark: T-Theres a penis out here
Jack: It was the echo of your foot steps
Jack: Are you still a clorox bleach
Bob: mmMaybe
Jack: Thats a firm Negatory
Jack: On the bleach-aroo
Bob: UH why don't you just drink some of me
Bob: cAUSE YOU SUCK!
Bob: Suck at finding- God dammit Fuck you
Jack: Hes a VACUUM
Jack: No?
Bob: No I'm actually just clorox bleach
Jack: aH Ok
Bob: hEY
*Explosion*
Mark: whOA
*Jack and Bob Laugh*
Mark: WHOA
Jack: gOTTEM!
Mark: whwhoa
Mark: You gottem!
Jack: I found 'em
Bob: Jesu-es christ
Mark: Holy shit
Jack: I can't help
Mark: You got that room
Bob: I didn't think you'd be so fuckin'
Wade: I'm interally still embarrassed
Wade: 'bout whenever I knew Mark was trashcan
Wade: I got scared when mark was the trash can
Mark: Hhehehe
Jack: I smell what you're farting
Bob: Not that I was playing with that
Bob: but
Mark: Huh I smell whats coming outta your ass hole
Jack: I smell your sphinct
Bob: You smell that stuff leaking out of my anoos?
Mark: Dude have you done something new to your sphinct
Mark: Thats a nice sphinct
Jack: Dude
Wade: o hey bob
Bob: just walking for once
Wade: 'ey bob Hows your sphinct
Bob: Clean and minty fresh
Jack: Hows your spanx going bro?
Wade: o hey
Mark: ahHHH HA
Mark: jesus christ
Jack: Not so good heh
Mark: NAHHHHHH HA HOO
Mark: WAH
Bob: wade wha Hahheh
Wade: He's a tin can
Mark: No I'm not
Mark: You're a tin can
Jack: These are all good sounds
Mark: you're a tin can
Mark: We're all tin cans
Jack: We're all tin cans
Mark: We're all tin cans?
Mark: aAHHHH
Wade: You see 'em bob?
Mark: nANOOOOOOOOOO
Bob: No hes still out here hes runnin' around like crazy
Mark: aHH FUCK
Bob: There you go
Jack: Great
Wade: I was going to let you let you run 'till you tried to go inside
Mark: ooOAOAOH OH SURE OAOAOH oh okay Alright
Mark: Sure yeah whatever
Bob: O my god I'm so sneezy
Mark: Quit bein' dUMB
Mark: God, The only reason they got me is cause
*Bob sneezes*
Mark: they're so dumb
Bob: *achoo* ha bub wa!
Mark: bless
Jack: Heh I know right
Mark: papa bless
Bob: nnA
Wade: aww Jack which one are ya
Jack: Im neither of all of them
Mark: hehaheha
Wade: Jack just opened a door on me
Mark: Taunting laugh
Jack: Maybe I opened up several doors
Mark: HEH HA HA H EHOH YOU'RE SO STUPID
Wade: Bob did you open this door here?
Bob:  What door
Wade: this one
Bob: 'ey I found him
Jack: are you fuckin' serious
Wade: O look there he goes
Mark:*laughter* heh rUNN RUNNN RUUUN
Bob: He's in the green room right now
Bob: He's trying to run away but he's not
Bob: Now he's in the bathroom
Bob: Like a dumb
Bob: Now he's in the green room He's right here
Jack:  No Im nOT
Jack: IM nott
Bob: Close the doors on him
*mark's laughter*
Wade: Nooo I diiid
Jack: Later buddy
Wade: but he opened it....
*explosion*
Bob: wHAT
Mark: wow
Jack: HA
Mark: You guys are awful HEHEHA
Jack: There's too much line of sight here!
Mark: aaAAAHHhh
Jack: AHH
Jack: AHHH
Mark: awww You almost had  it ya almost had it
Mark: You almost made a good gosh darn fool of that
Bob: fuck you t-pose bitch
Wade: yEAH
Mark: You just tea-bagging shards
Mark: of glass on the ground like yEAH
Mark: Im really getting ya now!
Mark: On a scale of wrong place to washing machine on the wall
Mark: how are- how screwed are you
Bob: Alright, alright, fuck.
Bob: Alright, dick.
Shit. Fuck.
Oh Lord, Oh God
Wade: Do you have to be so violent?
Jack: He's on the roof
Mark: He's on the roof?
Oh! He IS on the roof.
Mark: Well what are you gonna do?
Wade: [incomprehensible] ♪Halabala part time guurl ♪
Wade: ♪Jack your're the one I hold your heart in need ♪
[incomprehensible] ♪jajagibi You make me plead♪
Mark: I'm trying to keep a watch
I just don't know where he's going.
Mark: Welp, nevermind I don't need to watch anymore.
Jack: Nah, he's stupid. He could've left
Mark: ooOOP hello!
Mark: Bye bob
Bob: nO HANG ON!
Bob: Wait pause!
Mark: I-I'm pausing! Bob: I had an idea but I coudn't do it!
Mark: I'm pausing!
Mark: Well stop running if we're gonna pause!
Mark: I'm still pausing! Bob: Hang on!
Bob: Hang on!
Mark: What's up?
Jack: I didn't say I'd pause.
Bob: I'm gonna go over this way okay?
Mark: Okay. Alright, Okay
Bob: A littl--uh AH Ah
Mark: Hey I'm not shooting at ya.
I'm not shooting at ya
Bob: Alright, No I wanna try and get into the tree
house and be the big pumkin
Mark: Okay Alright
Bob: And you can kill me as the white pumkin okay?
Mark: you know what? You know what
Mark: I-I trust you
You know I usually EUUGHDon't trust you
But I trust you this time
Bob: I don't know why you wouldn't trust me
Mark: Yeah I don't know why either, you know?
Bob: Like, I'm gonna take the sidewalk so
you can see me the whole time. Okay?
Mark: Okay, cool! I'm ready for this
Mark: This is cool. This is good stuff.
This is good stuff
Mark: I feel together. I feel like, REALLY together.
Bob: Okay, I can't get in into the tree house from here
Also I'm crying right now cuz my eyes are watering
But I don't want to give up on this idea.
Mark: Okay get in the tree house
Bob: I'm gonna go up the ladder
Mark: Okay go up
Bob: Okay
Jack: Hey Buddy!
Mark: Alright, You're up there
Bob: Hi
Bob: Aw you CAN'T become this pumkin
ALL: OH YEAH; OH NO.
Bob: Goddamn
Bob: I literally cried for that shit to happen
Mark: Awww, I'm sorry
Bob: What the hell is happening? My eyes! It hurts
Wade: Well, maybe you shouldn't have rubbed them earlier
Wade: ASSWAGON
Bob: I didn't scratch my cornea, Wade.
Jack: [mocks] ASSwagon
Bob: I just saw Wade's enraged reign in your chat
Jack: You fucking charriot of tits!
Mark: Hi Jack..
Bob: Hi.
Jack: AHH
Mark: Jesus!
Mark: Well that does not bode well for me
Jack: OOOHHHHH
Jack: OOOH(transitions to giggles)
Jack: You can come in and out from there
Mark: Yeeaaaahh
Jack: OoOoOoOhhh
Jack: Yeah you should be good
Bob: Mark, what the fuck? Where'd you go?
Jack: Maybe less good now
Bob: Mark's a cinder block. Where the fuck did he just go?
Mark: *Evil Laughter*
Jack: How'd you lose him?
Mark: I don't know. I don't know, they're bunch of dumbs
Wade: Bob! Every door is open, he could've left at any point
Mark: no nO NO No no
Mark: It reALLy didn't work well for him
that's all im saying
Bob: I think I know were Mark is actually
Mark: WhERe pfft
Jack: Say it out loud and I'll say if you're right
Bob: He's in the big pit where the giant skeleton is..
*Mocking laughter*
Jack: You are incorrect
Mark: I'm in the big pit?
*Continued laughter*
Jack: Who even-who even thinks that?
Mark: Do you even have a brain?Jack: Lame-o!
Wade: Oh that's you I was like "Who's throwing stuff at me?"
Bob: Mark's right there he's a bottle
he's on the other side of that fence I just saw that!
Mark: Nu'uh! Nu'uh! NU'uh
Bob: No he's behind you!
Mark: aaAAAaaah
I hit a barrel! I hit a barrel!
Wade: HE'S A CINDER BLOCK
Mark: I'm a barrel! No I'm not
Bob: He's a big barrel!
Mark: waAAaay fuck you
Jack: He's a barrel now that can't be him Mark was a cinder block!
Mark: Aww shit!
*Laughs all round*
Bob: You just killed a stranger! Dumb!
Wade: Oh my God I did! I'm so sorry!
Jack: I think were bad at being props
Mark: MMMMM
Bob: I think all of us might be idiots
Mark: I did pretty good
'cause I-I gave them the ringer when I was in the building and escaped
J: You did
M: I gave them the slip.
B: Yeah I-
W: We did get the old, um, ringer.
J: I'll start shoving shit around.
M: I'll start inserting things in my ass.
B: um
M: That'll help
*Bob laughing*
J: Did you-did you just leave?
M: Hmmmmm
B: Um NO
J: Did you do it? Did you do what I think you did?
B: No
B: No it's fine, this is fine. Don't worry about it.
J: Oh maan
*Bob laughing again*
J: Oh man. I heard another door.
M: Oh no that was me upstairs. Did you get goofed? Did they goof you?
B: That was Mark up here don't worry about it.
J: Yeah...
M: Are you covered in goof juice?
J: The door down here opened and someone left.
M: OH NOO
M: Oh there's so much gooftoplasm everywhere-WOAH
J: [unintelligible] OH *uses grenade*
B: *high pitched scream*
M: Woah hoh ho aho
B: What the fuck man?
J: You can't be bleach again
M: Woah. That's a little extreme.
B: I didn't mean to be bleach. I was a paint can and I accidentally became bleach.
M: Alright.
J: Ahh
B: I was trying to become a frying pan but you can't be those.
M: Okay, Wadeywoo.
J: That sucks.
M: Where you at Wadeywoo?
J: Oh god there's a fuckin' room with dolls in it.
W: I am... around
M: Around huh?
J: It's a pentagram of dolls
B: CAN you find him? So duh.
B: Can you find him?
M: I-I get it. I get it.
J: CAN OF
B: So
da
can
you find him?
J: *laughs* he's a so da can
B: He's literally running laps around someone right now in a-in a not too obvious but kinda funny way
J: Okay, indoors? outdoors?
B: Mmm there's still two minutes left.
M: Woah, I saw something
B: That was a great fucking clue
M: I saw something!
B: *laughing* God damn Wade
M: I saw something Waad.
B:  Wade doesn't give a shit about doors.
W: NO *laughs*
B: He opens them, he closes them.
M: What's going on Wade? Huh?
W: Nothing. What's going on with you?
J: I don't have a grenade anymore so you're on your own with that.
M: I got a gre na de
B: Oh god please, please Wade
B: Woah
M: WOAH
*BOOM*
M: BOW
*everyone laughing*
J: NICE
W: SHIT I was doing that the whole match.
M: Nononono I don't think you were. No, I-I intended to leave it-
W: Yeah and every time Jack heard a door open, you were like "Oh that's me upstairs" and I was like "NOPE it was me"
J: I-I broke my game. It's constantly vibrating
B: Awesome
B: sexy
J: *laughs*
M: Wow
W: Well, see ya Jack
J: You can-you can't jump out of the tree-house then? No?
M: Yeah that's-you gotta jump for the hill. That's what I did before. That was my error.
B: There's also a stack of boxes on the-on the back side across the fence you can jump on.
W: Why'd you immediately jump off?
J: 'Cause you came up!
M: Hey , why are you throwing things out of that tree house? Come on, don't be so rude.
M: Don't be so rude! Don't be so rude
W: Oh Mark exists. He's a prop somewhere.
M: Hey I see you on that, I see you on there, on that, tree top, the tree house
M: I see you, I see you right now. Yeah, hi, waving to you.
B: Do you see me?
J: Bob, you're no where close
B: I'm not in the tree tops dummy.
J: No, you're out picking up watermelons.
M: Wade then? Whoever that is.
B: Yeah, I'm doing stuff.*gunfire*
M: They're a goof. HA  what a goof shot. What a goofy shot.
J: This man is a pervert. If seen contact Dwight Schrute.
M: What a goof. What a-what a -what a straight up goof.
M: Straight up goof man.
W: *drops grenade*
M: AH FUCK
B: Wow. I didn't even need-
M: Were you looking at me? It did not look like you were looking at me.
W: I was looking at you. I was watching you slide to the ladder.
M: Ahh man!
*Bob and Wade laughing*
B: Ha ha
M: I thought I got in there
W: I didn't see you until you walked into the ladder.
M: I know, yeah, but I was like, it was like you were looking straight out the whole time when I was doing it.
M: Damn it! *serious voice* It comes down to this.
It comes down to this guys.
B: This is the pivotable-pivit-pivibable thing
W: You okay Bob?
M: You alright Bob?
B: This is the thing. Do it
M: Oh, I see a toilet *laughs*
W: What do you mean?
M: There's just a-there's just a walking toilet.
M: With the-with the top part
J: Beware of the spooks
M: the top part and everything
B: Why you reading my sign Jack?
B: I'm literally standing right in front of you right now
J: In front of me?
B: Not when you turned to your left.
B: Now I'm standing right behind you.
B: Now I'm standing right to your left.
W: Hi
M: Oh hi. *laughs*
B: Now I'm right in front of you.
W: How's it goin'?
M: Ah, it's pretty good you know? It's alright.
M: How's being a-how's being a toilet?
B: I'm T'd up for you Jack
W: I mean, it's pretty cool actually.
B: I'm T'd up right here man.
M: It bring a lot of value to this tree house, you being a toilet
M: Because there wasn't a toilet in this tree house before.
W: Yeah, I thought so too
*Jack laughing*
B: Hi, you see me?
J: Hi
W: Well, I wanted to up the quality for resale
M: You sure did
*Mark and Wade laughing*
M: Alright.
J: How the...?
B: *gasps*
W: BOB NO
*everyone but Mark laughs*
M: Woaaahh that's embarrassing.
J: Did you get scared 'cause Jack was coming?
B: Yeah, well I was trying to use my back ladder escape. Didn't work.
W: Oh we gotta vote, we gotta vote
M: I'm not voting
W: Nevermind we're not voting.
*outro music*